[Music]
hello everyone Perry you back here with
another exclusive tip 2019 interview I'm
very excited about this one I already
told you guys I love C Fever this movie
it's just like so right up my alley and
for my taste in creature features it was
very very into it to kick this off with
you a lengthy TV career and this is your
first feature why make your future debut
with this particular story well it's a
story that means a lot to me I what
we're trying to do is make something
that it's a propulsive and exciting
adventure story but also has meaning and
has heart and soul and tells the story
that we feel needs to be told right now
just because I have a feeling a lot of
people out there don't know what sea
fever is does anyone want to give like
the quick elevator pitch they go like a
one-cent I feel like the one sentence
description I don't know why I'm asking
is that they go out on a boat and a
mysterious creature attaches itself to
it I'm gonna leave it at that
I think that's okay much what happens
it's the story of a marine biologist who
joins a very tight-knit crew on ragged
roller and with this one one of the
things that impresses me most is that
there's no real villain in the piece
whether we're talking about you know any
of the people on the boat or even the
creature for that matter it's just
beings trying to survive so with that in
mind can you guys each tell me one
quality about your character that you
would want to keep with you for yourself
one thing about my character I see him
as a survivor with the backstory we have
on this character is that he had been
through some stuff and he experienced
some stuff that a human being shouldn't
you know see in a lifetime so and he's
there and he has to be there to protect
his family and he's a survivor you know
he where he comes from people that even
died there are real survivors even
though they died so he made it and he's
just trying to be there and protect
people I think I probably would you know
my character has a sense of recklessness
in some degree but ultimately I think
he's a lot braver than I am in the sense
of what he does to sacrifice for his
family
Thurmond is wife and especially as
sacrifice he makes it at the end of the
film and I think he's really brave a lot
braver than I am so I'd like maybe a bit
of his bravery I'd say the ability to go
against the grain to not go with what's
popular to go what she thinks is right
but might not not necessarily be right
for everyone and to have such conviction
in what she believes in and what she
thinks it's true my character I think
what I would take away from her is like
she's sort of a unifier she sort of like
tries to get everybody to be a team to
try to get her husband to do the right
thing she she respects everybody on her
team and even Hermione's character she
she tries to make sure that she is
welcomed in so it's like this unifier I
think it's a really good quality to have
I think that's an appropriate choice
there what was it like shooting this
film are we basically talking stages and
tanks here I think we shot the first
week was shot on a trailer on the on
Detroit that you see in the film which
is a working trawler a family trawler
yeah I think working that first week on
the trawler was really valuable it was
thank you very much it gave everybody a
real sense of what that world is like
who those people are and Connie and do
great learned how to how to pilot the
trawler
went out with the guys really got a
handle on what it means to be in charge
of of everybody's lives like that when
you go out to sea and Coney also became
an expert fish gutter which I was very
impressed by so I think him that that
initial set of filming days where we
were out on the trawler then informed
everything else that happened in the
story originally we were thinking about
filming the entire film on the trawler
but actually of course below deck is so
tight and space is at such a premium
that we couldn't actually get the gear
down and have the actors and to have the
crew there so we recreated it on stages
and we set it up such that the actors
were totally free to move around the
full space of the boat
and we were able to make sure that the
camera always feels like it's inside the
boat it's never outside the but it's
always there right there in that
confined space but at least we could
take out walls and have the lands there
without you know 50 big hairy guys on
set beside the actors as you having a
crew even when we were like inside of
the stage it still felt tight you know
everything was still very tight inside
of our stage right was there anything
especially challenging with that kind of
setup that you've never experienced
before or any maybe specific scene
whether it's something where you're
actually out on the boat or in tight
quarters on a stage the boat when we
actually the first week of filming were
actually on the trawler that was pretty
tough because you know you're on the sea
and it's not very stable on a ship and
you got to have sea legs and not
everyone had SELEX so there's a lot of
heave-ho going on but it was it was
while there was yeah but it was it was
great in order you know to be on on the
trawler because you've got a real sense
of of that world and also the owners of
the trawler Brendan and his wife they
were around all the time looking kind of
disparaging me the begin unlike Rory I'm
learning to get better they were great
and it was you know it was it was a
great experience that first week you
know in the end the studio was was a
great recreation a recreation of the the
ship itself of the the trawler itself I
felt confined space with full roof and
that sense of the long narrow space of
the boats where there's nowhere to hide
you know you're really living
cheek-by-jowl with these other people so
I got the five minutes already and I
don't want to move on from sea fever but
we have a little game that we want to
play with you guys before and before I
do this I'm gonna say keep an eye out
for sea fever I freaking love this movie
it thrilled me to no end and it's so
nice to get a thoughtful thrill that
leaves you with something important to
think about after so thank you for that
all right we're gonna play a little
Collider most memorable moments so
rapid-fire around the table I'm gonna
list out seven topics and I want you to
tell me the first
that comes to your mind as this most
memorable moment so starting off your
most memorable film premiere whether
it's a movie you're in or one you
attended well this one without a dash
any other options for this one I have a
quite an embarrassing one I mean I
didn't move a years ago code ever after
and I turned up with the frame year in
Italy with a purple velvet suit on I
thought it looked cool looking at
pictures but now I think I might have
made a different choice in retrospect I
think for me it was gladiator we like we
basically were on the steps of the
Colosseum when we did our world premiere
there and it was kind of amazing
yeah for me must be my first feature
were in San Sebastian and it was it was
my first lead role and I hadn't seen the
film and I was nervous it was full full
theatre and I didn't know it was a
spotlight coming on later and they were
gonna film us so I was sitting there
like this shocked and then the lights
came on and out probably well this one
definitely but another one be xxx cuz we
arrived on a boat and I didn't realize
we were being along the Thames I didn't
realize we were being filmed the whole
way so I was like throwing my shoes off
like scratching my head like I didn't
know what was going then I arrived
apparently on the big screen everyone
has been watching us the whole time so
that was memorable so you really won't
ever forget it what is your most
memorable meal oh my god that's really
hard you're gonna have to come back to
me on that one
I think French Laundry in California
actually just had a meal the other day
and a restaurant in Vancouver called
Bauhaus which is owned by the director
le beau what an incredible meal that was
that was the the most recent memorable
meal I've ever had I have to say I had
lamb testicles once I had a similar
thing I ate at a restaurant called the
carnival and I don't really eat meat and
it was they would get snake kangaroo
like the one in Nairobi yep mm-hmm
that was pretty memorable yet circling
back around do you know what the thing
that actually comes to mind is I had
orange juice in a Danish pastry after
the birth of my second child and it was
the most delicious food I ever had all
right I'm about to get kicked out one
more let's do most memorable scene
you've ever shot oh I know okay
mission to Mars for me I'm hanging up on
wires and Tim Robbins is playing my
husband and he's dying and every time I
scream I start moving except in space
you don't move so I had to scream
without moving and burst in tears and I
literally thought this must be the worst
conditions for an actor ever my whole
life and I do not know how they edited
it so because I must have moved every
time it's impossible not to so that was
I remember that I remember I was on a
dinghy in a stormy water
it always seemed really cold it was
really stormy that was there just it was
sea fever yeah it was fun
oh I'm gonna say the last shot we did on
this film because we were in a diving
tank in Sweden and it was huge
you couldn't heat the this tank and I
had to dive down and swim down as far as
I could bearing in mind I had to swim
back up again for that final shot
there's the end of the film and that was
memorable because it was the last film
we also the last scene we shot so I
wrapped up very beautiful shot - yeah
listen I think I'd have to say the time
that I actually had a motorbike crash
during the film and broke my ribs busted
my knee busted my shoulder punctured my
lung but I got up and walked away there
you go even in the film do you want to
throw in one last one for us
most memorable scene most memorable
scene do you know what in sea fever
there's a there's a really beautiful
scene between Connie and ducrai and it's
an it's this really powerful emotional
moment which is the last scene that you
have together and you can oh no but it
was it was so lovely that we shot it one
shot two takes and it's just perfect and
that's a really memorable scene for me
and seriously I could talk about this
movie for hours if we weren't getting
kicked out right now thank you so much
for your time a huge congratulations to
all of you thank you to everybody out
there watching this interview right now
and another thank you to our wonderful
sponsor Nordstrom Canada for making
these interviews happen please do not
forget to like and share this video
before you go and tune in soon because
we're gonna have more TIFF coverage
coming your way very very soon